the recovery is progressing at a
moderate pace supported mainly by our
monetary policy measures and there are
favorable impact on financial conditions
as well as by the low price of energy
investment remains weak in the euro area
the situation in the banking sector now
is very different from what it was in
2012 perhaps most importantly euro area
banks have significantly strengthened
their capital positions over the past
few years there is a subset of banks
with elevated levels of non-performing
loans however these NPLs have since been
adequately provisioned for it is
becoming clearer and clearer the fiscal
policies should support the economic
recovery through public investment and
lower taxation the ideal objective of
this negotiation would be to anchor the
UK in European Union and having the
European Union and UK working together
we should take this opportunity for
deepening our monetary union integration
the 500 euro note is being viewed as
increasingly an instrument for illegal
activities so it's in this context that
we are considering action on that front
I it seems to be careful